-There's so much
going on right now.
I mean, there's --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Today, Rudy Giuliani
appeared before a grand jury
in Georgia to testify about
election interference.
HBO is about to debut
its "Game of Thrones"
prequel series,
"House of the Dragon."
[ Cheers ]
-Doctors are telling people
to stop doing a TikTok challenge
where you tape your mouth shut
while you sleep.
[ Laughter ]
And Capri Sun recalled
thousands of drinks
because they might contain
cleaning solution.
-Yeah, there's a lot to go over.
Let's just jump in
and cover it all at once.
It's time for a "News Smash."
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
First up,
Rudy Giuliani is in trouble.
He's the target
of a Georgia investigation
into election interference.
[ Laughter ]
When he found out,
Rudy shouted a bunch of words
that you can only say on...
-HBO.
[ Laughter ]
They're about to debut a huge
new "Game of Thrones" prequel
called "House of the Dragon."
It takes place 200 years
before the original,
and it's a great idea, unlike...
-Taping your mouth shut
before you go to sleep.
[ Laughter ]
People are doing it on TikTok,
but doctors say
it's bad for your health.
Kind of like...
-Drinking Capri Sun
spiked with cleaning solution.
They've recalled
thousands of drinks,
not to mention those pouches,
which can often...
-Leak. Rudy...
[ Laughter ]
...does it all the time.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Now he's under investigation
by the state of Georgia
and the feds.
I mean, there's no way that guy
is getting much...
-Sleep.
[ Laughter ]
Come on, TikTok.
Mouth tape, tortilla slapping,
the face-wax challenge.
Seems like the only thing
y'all don't allow is...
-Nudity. "House of the Dragon"
will have lots of it.
So fingers crossed
none of the actors look like...
-Rudy Giuliani.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
I mean, just look at that face.
That guy
could definitely use some...
-Cleaning solution.
[ Laughter ]
Drinking that would be gross.
Almost as gross as...
-Hooking up with your sibling.
[ Laughter and groans ]
It happened
on "Game of Thrones,"
and it could happen again.
But I'm excited for the dragons.
They breathe fire.
And so will you
if you swallow...
-Pine-Sol Capri Sun.
[ Laughter ]
So, in conclusion...
-Ice and fire.
-Total liar.
-Nighttime ouch.
-Clorox pouch.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This has been a "News Smash."
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]